bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct et france cette victoire de la
droite favorite dans la capitale
espagnole depuis plus de 25 ans ce n'est
pas vraiment une surprise
non effectivement la plupart des
sondages prévoyez cette victoire et les
dernières enquêtes d'opinion avant leur
interdiction puisqu'en espagne on ne
peut pas en publier durant la semaine
qui précède le scrutin donc les
dernières enquêtes d'opinion
prévoyez même laissé même envisagé une
possible majorité absolue d'isabelle dia
faille ou sow alors elle ne s'est pas
produite
mais elle n'est pas passé si loin que
cela puisque la majorité absolue est à
69 sièges et qu'elle seule l'a 65
de même le mauvais score global de la
gauche et en particulier des socialistes
et de podemos était largement anticipée
par les sondages
comment un les madrilènes ont réagi face
à cette réélection
évidemment ça dépend de du parti qu'il
soutenait un pour lequel ils s'étaient
mobilisés
on a quand même vu un très large
consensus à madrid via le score du parti
populaire et via le score delà de
l'extrême droite de la droite radicale
de vox on a vu un consensus se dégage et
donc autour de la gestion de la pandémie
par la présidente régionale notamment
depuis juin 2020 puisque entre mars et
juin 2020 à la gestion de la pandémie
était national en espagne au plus dur de
la première vague et ensuite cette
gestion et d'administration est revenu
aux régions espagnoles est donc depuis
juin 2001 la présidente régionale
isabelle 10 a failli ou sow s'est
singularisée en espagne y compris au
sein de son parti par toute une série de
mesures
brive voire opposées à déconfinement
massif favorable aux affaires favorable
à l'ouverture tous les lieux économique
et culturel est véritablement je pense
qu'une majorité de madrilène s'est
retrouvé dans cette stratégie et dans
cette volonté de
vivre le plus normalement ou le moins a
normalement possible malgré les
circonstances
alors c'est un coup dur pour pedro
sanchez ce scrutin ce qu'ils pourraient
affaiblir le président du gouvernement
espagnol
évidemment pedro sanchez on ressort
affaibli ce n'est pas pour autant que
qui est que sa majorité relative au
parlement national va être immédiatement
remise en cause mais il en sort affaibli
d'autant qu'il s'était beaucoup investie
durant la campagne alors surtout au
début et puis quand il a commencé à
constater qu'elles sont là j'étais très
favorable il s'est mis un peu en retrait
pour éviter d'être trop éclaboussé par
la défaite mais malgré tout évidemment
il est très affaibli
et il est d'autant plus affaibli que son
partenaire de coalition en idas podemos
malgré une progression de trois sièges
depuis 2010 9 fait un score décevant et
ce qui ce qui provoque la le retrait de
la vie politique de pablo iglesias à
propos de podemos pablo iglesias à
l'allié de pedro sanchez qui se retire
de la politique
comment interpréter cette décision et
quelles conséquences pour pedro sanchez
cette décision peut être interprétée de
différentes façons d'abord il faut
comprendre que podemos est sur le déclin
électoral depuis des années en réalité
depuis 2015 podemos non seulement ne
progresse plus à toutes les élections
qu'elles soient nationales régionales ou
municipales mais régresse l'année
dernière aux élections régionales
galicia des basques podemos à encaisser
de sérieuse défaite cette année en
catalogne le parti en tout cas ses
alliés locaux en catalogne à a réussi à
sauver les meubles mais n'a guère fait
mieux
don pablo iglesias était déjà très
affaibli et santé vient le vent du
boulet arriver à ces prêts lui il faut
aussi comprendre qu'à madrid c'était une
lutte entre deux gauche radicale celle
de pablo iglesias avec poser moss et
celle de son ancien numéro 2 inigo efron
avec mass madrid
qui lui a fait beaucoup mieux et puis je
crois qu'il faut aussi interpréter ce
retrait de la vie politique et cette
déception très forte pour pablo iglesias
dans le cas de sa démission en tant que
deuxième vice-président du gouvernement
il a démissionné pour se lancer dans la
bataille des élections madrilènes
en réalité on sait depuis longtemps par
diverses rumeurs très insistantes que
les relations entre pablo iglesias et
pedro sanchez était mauvaise et que
pablo iglesias avait l'impression de ne
pas pouvoir influencer réellement la
politique du gouvernement national et de
le faire que payer les pots cassés de
cette politique alors on l'a présenté le
scrutin de madrid comme un test pour les
futures élections nationales votre avis
là-dessus alors je pense qu'il faut être
très prudent
effectivement c'est est vue comme un
test parce que les communautés autonomes
espagnoles en général ont beaucoup plus
d'attributions et beaucoup plus de
marges financières que les régions
françaises donc leur poids est bien
supérieure et par ailleurs madrid c'est
le joyau de la couronne pour ainsi dire
dans les régions espagnoles
c'est la troisième région la plus
peuplée c'est la région la plus riche en
pib absolue en pib par habitant
c'est la locomotive économique de
l'espagne
donc bien sûr tout le monde et
principalement les
les vainqueurs du scrutin tentent de
faire une lecture nationale du scrutin
je pense pour ma part qu'il va falloir
attendre un petit peu notamment parce
que la droite est très bien implantée à
madrid il ya le gouvernent depuis 26 ans
en région depuis 1995 que cette
domination n'est pas forcément
transposable à l'ensemble du pays donc
je me montrerai plus prudent que
certains analystes qui analyse qui
explique que tout cela à une
interprétation nationale évidente
merci beaucoup à vous une école à klein
je rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste de
l'espagne auteur de comprendre l'espagne
d'aujourd'hui manuel de civilisation aux
éditions ellipses